IL-SUNG LEE: Hi, everyone.
My name is Il-Sung Lee, and
I'm a senior product manager
for Google Cloud working
on key management
and obviously,
Cloud HSM With me, I
have Adit Sinha, who's one of
our tech leads for Cloud HSM,
to talk about Cloud
HSM and give you
a deep dive and best practices
around the service itself.
In this session, we'll talk
first about the HSM overview
and give you an idea
of what Cloud HSM is
and what it can do
for you, and then
highlight some of the key
features for Cloud HSM.
Then I'll turn it over to
Adit, who will actually
talk more about the
overall architecture
and talk about some of the
key aspects of architecture,
such as tenant separation and
Google administrative access.
So start off with, let's
go and talk a little bit
about the overview of Cloud HSM.
That picture there is
actually a real picture of one
the cards that we have
inside our data centers.
This is a Cavium
LiquidSecurity HSM.
That black stuff you
see all around it
is actually epoxy
that's used to provide
tamper evidence and tamper
resistance for the card itself.
And it's one of the
requirements for the card
to be a FIPS 140-2 card, and
I'll explain a little bit more
about that in a bit.
But the Cloud's HSM
service is basically--
HSM is a managed service.
And so, if you're not
familiar with HSMs,
they're hardware
security modules.
They're basically industry
devices that are used--
hardware devices that are
used to actually protect
generated key material and
also perform crypto operations.
Now, the Cloud HSM
that we provide
is actually a fully managed
service that Google provides,
as you can see in
the diagram there.
A request comes in.
It goes through the key
management service front end.
And then based upon the
type of key your created,
it either goes to a software
path or the hardware path.
If it's in the hardware
path, our Cloud HSM servers
will orchestrate the
operations to occur within one
of the actual physical HSMs.
So the architecture
actually lends itself
to being a full cloud service.
And I won't talk too much about
this, because in a few slides,
Adit will talk more about this.
But what I mean is
that we'll take care
of all the patching for you.
So you don't have
to worry about any
of the physical maintenance,
firmware, upgrades
or anything else like that.
It's all done
without any downtime.
So it doesn't really make a--
it doesn't really impact
you from an availability
perspective.
We also auto scale on this,
in terms of requests as well.
If you have a lot of
requests, then our service
will just be able to fulfill
all those requests as well
within the limits of your quota.
The other thing
is that you don't
have to worry about backups
and having a kind of business
continuity strategy, because
we'll take care of that for you
as well.
So we'll take care
of the backups.
We have a very, very,
highly redundant system
that'll make sure that your
key material is very secure,
and that the chances
of losing your keys
are actually extremely small
to almost complete unlikely.
The other thing about
the HSMs as well
is that they're all contained
within our very secure
facilities.
And so they're-- basically
inherit all the physically
securities of all our servers
and all the other devices have
within our data centers.
And they basically provides
a level of security
that will be pretty hard to
impersonate outside of a cloud
provider.
Why would you use Cloud HSM?
There's a number of reasons.
So number one, it's
typically compliance.
So a lot of people use Cloud
HSM, or HSMs in general,
because they're looking for
a certification from NIST.
It's essentially
FIPS 140-2 level 3
that our HSMs are
currently running in.
Now, what that means is that the
FIPS 140-2 is a crypto standard
devised by NIST again.
And it defines
things like what--
random number generations,
the type of algorithms,
key types, things like that.
The level 3 is basically only
attainable through hardware
devices.
And it dictates things like
the physical tamper evidence
and tamper proofness
of the device itself,
so that you can't get
in there and physically
try to extract the keys, or
it's very difficult to do so.
Regionalization is
also another key aspect
of the service where, when
you actually create a key
within a specific region--
let's say that it's
us-central1, then that key only
exists within us-central1.
And not only the key
but also the metadata,
all the backups, everything
else associated with that.
So wherever you create the
key, that's where it'll be.
Now, Cloud HSM also
provides an additional level
of regional affinity
based on the fact
that, when you
create the keys, it's
associated with a set of
HSMs that are physically
within that region.
If that key was ever--
if you ever tried
to actually decrypt
that key in a different
region, it's not possible.
You will understand what I'm
talking about a little bit more
when Adit talks about
the architecture,
but essentially that
key can only ever be
used by those devices
within that region.
And then finally, the last
thing, and I'll just reiterate,
is that it leverages the
exact same APIs as Cloud KMS.
What that really means
is that, if you already
know how to use Cloud KMS, then
you know how to use Cloud HSM.
Any application
that uses Cloud KMS
can use Cloud HSM, including
all the internal integrations
that we have as well.
So all the servers that are
integrated with our Cloud KMS
will be able to use HSMs
without any kind of changes.
It's only when you create the
key you specify protection
level and that's it.
Now, talking in terms
of key features,
there are three that I
like to actually cover
in a little more detail.
Those are the global
multi-regional support,
the attestation statements,
and the CMEK integration.
CMEK stands for Customer-Managed
Encryption Keys.
In terms of the global
multi-regional support, first
of all, we have Cloud HSM
available in all our cloud
regions.
So any region that
you choose today
should have Cloud HSM
available with it as well.
It has a large footprint.
It's probably one of the largest
footprints for HSM service
that you'll find anywhere,
to be quite honest.
The other thing is
that it will be--
you have the capability
of actually creating
a multi-region with
our Cloud HSM keys.
What that means
is that, when you
create a key in a
multi-region, it's
available across that geography.
For example, if you create
a key within the US region,
then that key is accessible
through different areas
within the United States.
It's available
across the country,
so that if for whatever reason
your particular region goes
dark, which hopefully
never happens,
then that key exists in
other areas and other regions
or other parts of the country,
so that your application can
migrate over to a different
part of the country
and the key will just be there.
It'll be completely available.
When you make changes to
a key in a multi-region,
the changes are
reflected everywhere.
So it happens almost
instantaneously.
So it's truly a multi-region.
It's not a backup and restore.
In other schemes,
you may see systems
where you actually are
taking your backup,
and restoring, and cloning
it to a different region,
so that you basically
mimic having two regions
and having a business
continuity solution.
Ours is a little bit
more automated than that.
Just define your key to
be in a multi-region,
and it does exists there.
We recently, also,
announced support
for a global, regional
support, which
means that if you create a
key within a global region,
that key becomes
available across--
around the globe.
So a key that's created, for
example, in the United States
may be also available in
India, or also available
across Europe if you
create it as a global key.
And for anyone who's actually
worked directly with HSMs,
you know that that is a pretty
special thing to be able to do,
because creating
clusters with HSMs
is not that simple,
especially when it
spans massive geographies.
Because of the
architecture that we
chose that Adit
will explain in bit,
you'll see why we can
actually do things
like this, which makes it
truly like a cloud service.
The second thing I want to
cover is attestation statements.
What an attestation
statement is,
is that it's a statement
that's signed by the HSM
using a certificate
by the HSM vendor,
that attests to the
key and the properties
around the keys
being inside the HSM.
So if you create a
key using our APIs,
then you can download that
attestation statement,
and verify the signature, and
know that the key is definitely
inside--
created by one of our HSMs.
And when you perform
a crypto operation,
it will happen within
the HSM itself.
Now, the other things you can do
with the attestation statement
is that you can look at the
various properties of the keys,
including things like whether
the key is extract or not.
So you can actually get
verifiable proof that that key
material cannot be taken
out HSM in plaintext,
and that Google
can't do this either.
This is something
that'll probably
make your auditors very happy.
Other things that
you can do are look
at the different properties.
One of the more
interesting ones is
that if you actually are
using a asymmetric key,
you can actually download the
SHA-256 hash of the public key
itself.
So when you download
a public key from HSM,
you can take those
SHA-256 hash, compare it
to the one that's in the
attestation statement,
and if they match, then
you know that you're
talking to the right
key and that you
have cryptographic
proof that you're
talking to a key within HSM.
The final thing I'll talk about
is customer-managed encryption
keys support services.
All the services
that you see here
are already integrated
with our Cloud KMS.
There's nine of them listed
in the integrated services.
On the virtue of
the fact that we've
designed Cloud HSM to
leverage the exact same API,
it means that anywhere
where Cloud KMS we use,
you can actually leverage
Cloud HSM as well.
The only difference
is, again, is
that when you create
the key, there's
a different flag that you set.
So, it's probably one of the
fastest experiences you'll ever
have in creating a key in
HSM Then with that key,
you can actually use it
to protect your data in,
for example Cloud SQL,
or GCS, or BigQuery,
or any of the
services listed there.
The CMEK compliant
services are services
that don't persist data in any
significant length of time,
which is why they're
CMEK compliant.
If you look at the
URL that I have
at the bottom of
the slide, this page
will be constantly updated
with new services that we add,
because we're
constantly trying to add
more services to the support
list for Cloud KMS and Cloud
HSM.
With that, I'm going to
add three more things
I want to actually talk about.
First, customers pay for
key operations not capacity.
What we're saying here is
that Cloud HSM is actually
a consumption based model.
You don't have to
basically purchase
an entire partition, or
partitions, or clusters
of partitions.
You basically pay for
every crypto operation.
Every key that you create.
I believe right now, it's $0.03
per 10,000 operations for most
type of operations, and it's
about $1.00 a month per key.
You can use as much as you want.
You can use as
little as you like.
It's bascially, there's
no upfront cost to this,
and there's no commitment.
There's no additional cost
for multi-regional operations.
Despite the fact that this
key can span multiple--
a vast geography, we don't
charge you any extra for that.
It's bascially the same
cost I just quoted above.
Finally, the high
availability is
inherent as a property
of the service itself.
There's no requirement for you
to actually take backups, store
the backups, or do
anything else like that.
We have a very,
very robust system
that takes very, very
frequent backups,
and takes the key
material and actually
backs them up into a
disparate system as well,
so that we are resilient against
failures of any particular data
store.
With that, now I'm
going to turn it over
to Adit, who's going to
talk a little bit more
about the architectural view.
ADIT SINHA: Thanks, Il-Sung.
Like Il-Sung said, I'll go
into more details about how
the architecture
works, and hopefully
make it clear how all the
features that Il-Sung talked
about fall out of our design.
I'll go more into detail about
a lot of different aspects.
But to start with, I
want to talk about some
of the design principles that
we have behind our system.
First, we want to
reduce user API access.
HSMs are inherently
complex devices
and are similar to black boxes.
In order to try to
prevent customers
from launching attacks against
the HSMs and the service,
we want to restrict
the types of operations
they're allowed to do.
Second, one of the major
reasons to move to the cloud
is to no longer need to
manage your own devices.
We want Cloud HSM to fit in
that same customer experience.
As Il-Sung said,
we want customers
to pay for
consumption model, not
for having to provision
their resources beforehand.
And third, a lot of customers
have compliance requirements
around where their keys
are geographically located.
We want strong cryptographic
and administrative controls
to make sure that we can
maintain these requirements.
The system that we've
designed for these principles
looks slightly different than a
normal HSM in the cloud model.
In the traditional model, you
would have crypto op access
represented by the
blue arrows and admin
access represented
by the red arrows
to your own partition on HSM.
The cloud provider would have
admin access to the device
as a whole, which they would
use for operations like setting
the HSM up initially for you.
In contrast, in Cloud HSM,
you only get crypto op access.
That access is to shared
partitions on the HSM,
and it's mediated by
the Cloud HSM service.
Google retains admin access to
both the partitions and the HSM
device.
The Cloud HSM service
is responsible for load
balancing and controlling
access to the HSM.
It can see plain texts,
but can't see key material.
Since these are fixed
devices, raw key material
must remain on the HSM.
Instead, the service can see
wrapped key material, which
uses extensively in the
system to make it scalable
and highly available.
Each region has a
wrapping key that's
replicated to a partition on
all of the HSMs in the region.
When you create a
key, the service
wraps your key with the
regions wrapping key
and collects the attestation.
It puts the wrapped key
in an external database.
When you want to do
a crypto operation,
the service will retrieve the
wrapped key from the database
and send it to an HSM
along with the inputs
to the crypto operation--
for example, with the
plaintext in an encryption.
The HSM will unwrap the
key and do the operation.
This scheme has a few benefits.
First, as soon as your key is
created, any HSM in the region
can use it immediately.
There is no
synchronization mechanism
that needs to happen online.
Second, the durability of your
keys isn't tied to the HSMs.
Your keys are all backed
up in an external database.
And third, regardless
of the number
of operations that you
have or the number of keys
that you have, all customers
experience the availability
of being backed by a full
region's worth of HSMs.
In order to scale
up in this model,
we'll install a new HSM in
the data center for the region
and clone the region's
wrapping key to that new HSM.
Additionally, if the
region is supposed
to support a multi-region, we'll
clone the multi-region wrapping
key to a separate partition.
For example, here we
have three cloud regions,
the first two of which also
support the same multi-region.
The HSMs in the first
two cloud regions
have a second partition
that is cloned
with the same
multi-regional wrapping key.
The HSMs in cloud region 3
don't have the second partition,
because the region doesn't
support the multi-region.
When you create a key
in a multi-region,
the process looks very
similar to that as a region.
The Cloud HSM service creates
the key in the partition
and wraps it.
This means that as soon as you
create a key in a multi-region,
it can be used immediately
anywhere in that multi-region.
We bootstrap off
the rest of Google's
synchronized databases.
Also, by using
separate wrapping keys
for different regions and
different multi-regions,
the service ensures that
keys can't be used outside
of their intended region.
For example, a key wrapped
with the region 1 wrapping
key can't be used
in cloud region 2,
because none of the HSMs in
region 2 can load that key.
Likewise, a key wrapped with
the multi-regional wrapping key
can't be used in cloud
region 3 for the same reason.
This ensures that once
we've set the system up,
it automatically enforces
regionalization constraints.
Setting the system up, that
is cloning the wrapping keys
across different HSMs, is
an administrative operation.
We have a different set
of controls to make sure
that happens safely.
First, only a small
number of Googlers
have permission to
perform admin operations.
The operations require M-of-N
authorization on the HSMs.
So the HSMs require
multiple Googlers
to authorize each
operation, and Googlers
need to provide two-factor
authentication in order
to do so.
All of the operations happen in
a secure and highly restricted
access facility.
We have extensive audit logs
both for access to the facility
and all of the operations
that happen inside.
Additionally, as
Il-Sung mentioned
that these are
fixed devices, they
don't allow specific
operations regardless
of who is doing them,
even HSM administrator.
For example, you can't
export plaintext key material
of either customer
keys or wrapping keys.
And finally, many of our
systems are built in such a way
to not allow HSM
administrators to perform
crypto operations even with
administrative credentials.
We have all these
mechanisms in place
to keep you safe from Googlers.
Other customers,
on the other hand,
only have crypto
operation access.
So to keep you
safe from them, we
have a different
set of mechanisms.
First, when a customer
does an operation,
we check whether they
have permission to do
the operation in Cloud IAM.
By using Cloud IAM, you
can use the same set
of permissions and
policies that you
use to manage the rest
of your cloud resources
to also manage your HSM keys.
Second, we check that the
customer has sufficient quota
to do the operation.
In order to make sure that
we have enough resources
to serve requests for your
workloads when you need them,
we need to make sure that other
customers aren't unexpectedly
overloading the service.
And third, we have basic request
validation before the request
reaches the HSM.
For example, we check
that different arguments
are within their
expected range in size
and also the key
types are correct.
This, coupled with the fact
that there is no customer admin
access, significantly reduces
the attacks surface available,
creating a safer product.
In summary, we've covered quite
a few details of about how
the Cloud HSM service works.
We've seen how we
use key wrapping
and partitions to make a highly
available and scalable service
that takes away the need for you
to manage your own HSM devices.
We've seen how this system keeps
you safe from both Googlers
and from other customers through
our administrative controls
and tenant isolation.
We've seen how you
can easily create keys
in regions and multi-regions.
The consequence of all
these design decisions
is that it is as easy
to protect your data,
both in Google
services and directly
as it is with a software key.
We'll have all of these details
and more in an upcoming Cloud
HSM white paper.
So please keep your
eye out for that.
Thank you.